Actually, it might put the operation at the back. So you might need to do a one rotate after you, uh, look at that. Everybody loves a rotate. And also, too, you need the splitting functions, which I have in a string library. And actually, I borrow the names of words and unwords from Haskell. Though a major difference is that I'm evaluating a... You're evaluating a string. You're doing a reduction on the integers.
实际上，它可能会把操作符放到最后。所以你可能需要在查看它之后进行一次旋转。每个人都喜欢旋转。此外，你还需要分割函数，我在字符串库中就有这些函数。实际上，我借用了 Haskell 中 words 和 unwords 的名称。不过一个主要的区别是，我正在评估一个……你正在评估一个字符串。你正在对整数进行归约。
Yeah, yeah. Very nice, though. Still like 90% the same. Yeah, exactly. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast. episode 268 recorded on December 22nd, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Ben, we chat about advent of code 2025 in C++ and BQN, day six.
是啊，是啊。不过真的很不错。仍然有 90% 是一样的。是的，没错。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客。第 268 期，录制于 2025 年 12 月 22 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Ben 一起聊聊 2025 年 Advent of Code 的第六天，使用 C++ 和 BQN。
You should try day six. I recommend that you in particular should try day six as an array language programmer. So day six, it's funny. I don't know at what point, but I was kind of sad. I was kind of sad at some point in the last couple of weeks because I had given up so quickly. And I was like, oh, you know, having a code. I might have been on a plane or something. And I was just like, you know, maybe I should go look.
你应该试试第六天。我特别建议你作为一名数组语言程序员去试试第六天。所以第六天，这很有趣。我不知道是在什么时候，但我当时有点难过。在过去几周的某个时候，我有点难过，因为我放弃得太快了。我当时想，哦，你知道，带着代码。我可能是在飞机上什么的。我当时只是想，你知道，也许我应该去看看。
And the first thing I was looking for was to see, was there a huge drop off after day three? I was hoping for my biases to be confirmed in that like they really messed up with day three. And that it just, you know, half as many people on day four were doing it. That was not the case. But then I went to look at was there a day that was easier. Because in years past every once in a while, they have like a day five or six or seven. and you're like, oh, this is much easier if you know the technique or whatever. Right.
我寻找的第一件事是看看第三天之后是否有巨大的流失。我希望我的偏见能得到证实，即他们在第三天真的搞砸了。而且，你知道，第四天做的人只有一半。事实并非如此。但我接着去看了看有没有哪一天更容易。因为在过去几年里，他们偶尔会有第五、第六或第七天。你会想，哦，如果你知道技巧什么的，这要容易得多。对吧。
Well, and the difficulty is definitely not linear, right? Erica said this. Sometimes he throws in an early one, which is quite difficult. Yes. And quite often, a later one will build on what came before. Interestingly, there's often also a sort of cellular automata thing going on. They're quite common for advent of code puzzles. And I think Day 4 was sort of like, yeah, day 4 was sort of like that,
嗯，难度绝对不是线性的，对吧？Erica 说过这一点。有时他会加入一个早期的问题，这相当困难。是的。而且通常情况下，后面的问题会建立在前面的基础上。有趣的是，通常也会有一种类似元胞自动机的东西。它们在 Advent of Code 的谜题中很常见。我认为第四天有点像，是的，第四天有点像那样，
but there wasn't the later one which built on it. Anyway, carry on. What were you going to say about day six? Well, no, I was going to say. So day six was the day that I had cherry picked. I didn't actually go and solve it, but I did think to myself, at least for Part A. I'm curious if you can tell me what Part B is, but Part A could be solved very, very cutely
但没有后续建立在它之上的问题。总之，继续吧。你刚才想说关于第六天的什么？嗯，不，我是想说。所以第六天是我精挑细选的那一天。我实际上并没有去解决它，但我确实对自己想，至少对于 A 部分是这样。我很好奇你能否告诉我 B 部分是什么，但 A 部分可以非常、非常巧妙地解决，
by basically just like transposing the matrix and then you have a value-primitive basically in all array languages where if you just construct a string that is a valid program, you can just execute it. So all you would need to do is insert a slash after the operation, which would be pretty easy, right? The binary operator. Well, I guess we should explain the problem if we're going to chat about this a bit. Do you want to explain it? Because you're the one that actually did it. I was just looking at it and not paying attention to what you said for the last 30 seconds.
基本上只需要转置矩阵，然后你在所有数组语言中都有一个值原语，如果你只是构建一个有效的程序字符串，你就可以直接执行它。所以你所要做的就是在操作符后面插入一个斜杠，这应该很容易，对吧？二元运算符。嗯，我想如果我们打算聊聊这个，我们应该解释一下这个问题。你想解释一下吗？因为是你真正做了它。我刚才只是在看它，并没有注意你过去 30 秒说了什么。
Sorry. So go, why don't you go ahead and explain? Yeah, I put the cart in front of the horse once again for like the sixth time in this conversation because I started explaining how you solve it without even mentioning anything about the problem. So you're going to say something though. But you're right. Like day six, if you have transpose, transpose is a big workhorse for day six. Big work course. Yeah.
抱歉。所以去吧，你为什么不继续解释呢？是的，我在这段对话中第六次把马车放在马前面了，因为我开始解释如何解决它，甚至没有提到关于问题的任何事情。不过你还是想说点什么。但你是对的。就像第六天，如果你有转置，转置是第六天的大功臣。大功臣。是的。
And I learned transpose in Python. Oh, yeah, yeah. The Star Star, Splat, whatever. Zip of Star. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Actually, I looked on Google Translate. Oh, did you?
我在 Python 中学到了转置。哦，是的，是的。星号星号，Splat，随便什么。Zip 星号。是的，是的。是的。实际上，我在谷歌翻译上查过。哦，你查了吗？
Because I was going to say it. I'm pretty sure I was literally just to bring it up. I don't know if it's there. I think it is. Maybe it is. I didn't know you want to search for. If you type transpose and then you, uh, uh, oh no, it's not. Interesting.
因为我正要说。我很确定我刚才正要提出来。我不知道它是否在那里。我想它是有的。也许是吧。我不知道你想搜索什么。如果你输入转置，然后你，呃，呃，哦不，它不在。有趣。
Python's. Oh, actually, wait. If I go show expressions, there it is. It's hidden. Here, let me share my screen for a set. Oh, okay. We'll share window next time. Maybe I'll tweet this out.
Python 的。哦，实际上，等等。如果我去显示表达式，它就在那里。它被隐藏了。来，让我共享一下我的屏幕。哦，好的。下次我们共享窗口。也许我会发推特。
Um, so if the default is turned. on that's kind of a it's kind of evil of me so you go to if you search transpose on who will translate a website I built except if you spell it correctly it brings up by default every function that matches that textual name but if you click on any and you can see that all of these have the exact same semantics because they're all the same color if you click on one of these now it'll show all of the functions across languages regardless of the name that match the semantics and D calls it transposed.
嗯，所以如果默认设置是开启的，那有点，那对我来说有点邪恶，所以你去，如果你在谷歌翻译网站上搜索转置，我构建的那个网站，除非你拼写正确，否则它默认会显示所有匹配该文本名称的函数，但如果你点击任何一个，你可以看到所有这些都有完全相同的语义，因为它们都是相同的颜色，如果你现在点击其中一个，它将显示跨语言的所有函数，无论名称如何，只要语义匹配，D 语言称之为转置。
Moon, which is esoteric language made by an individual that wanted to add it, calls it Zip, and Q calls it Flip. So I thought for sure I added this, but that's because I decided to hide expressions and
Moon，这是一种由想要添加它的人制作的深奥语言，称之为 Zip，而 Q 语言称之为 Flip。所以我以为我肯定添加了这个，但那是因为我决定隐藏表达式和
third-party libraries. Oh, okay. The ZipStar is not actually a function, but it's an expression. And so if you do that, ZipStar, sure enough, is the very last thing at the bottom from Python. Because when you said that, I was like, I'm pretty sure I added that to Google Translate. However, it is hidden. Okay. Makes sense. But I didn't see it. Right. Because star is, of course, just for people
第三方库。哦，好的。Zip 星号实际上不是一个函数，而是一个表达式。所以如果你这样做，Zip 星号，果然，是 Python 在底部的最后一项。因为当你那样说的时候，我就想，我很确定我把它加到谷歌翻译里了。然而，它被隐藏了。好的。有道理。但我没看到它。对。因为星号，当然，只是对于那些
who don't know Python, star is kind of the destructuring operator, right, which sort of takes the list to a pack of elements, if you like. And then, so if you have a list of lists and you say star of it, you get the pack of lists and then you zip them. And, of course, that gives you, you the first one of each, followed by the second one of each. So it's transpose. It's a magical incantation that somehow maps to transpose. But yes, day six, so it gives you a table of numbers that are spaced delimited. And at the bottom of each column is a binary operation, either multiply or plus. So the asterix or the plus sign. And it basically just asks you to, based on that binary operation, compute the reduction.
不懂 Python 的人来说，星号是一种解构运算符，对吧，它有点像把列表变成一包元素，如果你喜欢的话。然后，所以如果你有一个列表的列表，你说它的星号，你得到列表的包，然后你压缩它们。当然，这会给你每一个的第一个，后面跟着每一个的第二个。所以它是转置。这是一个神奇的咒语，不知何故映射到转置。但是是的，第六天，它给你一个空格分隔的数字表。每一列的底部是一个二元运算，要么是乘法，要么是加法。所以星号或加号。它基本上只是要求你，根据那个二元运算，计算该列的归约，并返回所有这些值的总和。所以用 BQN，加法或乘法归约字面上就是，我想你必须用乘法符号替换星号。我没意识到这一点。但你可以在每一件事后面加一个斜杠，然后这就变成了一个归约。如果你转置它，我想也许转置这个，不，是的，它会把，实际上它可能会把操作符放到最后。
of that column and return the sum of all those values. And so in BQN, a plus or multiply reduction is literally just, I guess you would have to replace the asteris with the multiplication symbol. I didn't realize that. But you could just add a slash to each of those things and then that becomes a reduction. And if you transpose it and I guess maybe transposing this, no, yeah, it will put the, actually it might put the operation at the back.
所以你可能需要在查看它之后进行一次旋转。看那个。每个人都喜欢旋转。而且，你还需要分割函数，我在字符串库中就有这些函数。实际上，我借用了 Haskell 中 words 和 unwords 的名称，因为它们太好用、太有用了。但你基本上可以在每一行上做 words，
So you might need to do a one rotate after you, look at that. Everybody loves a rotate. And also, too, you need the splitting functions, which I have in a string library. And actually, I borrow the names of words and unwords from Haskell because they're so nice and so useful. But you could basically do a words on each line,
把它放进一个矩阵里。在那一点上它必须是字符串，因为你有你的操作符。对它做一个旋转，或者做一个转置，然后做一个旋转，这会把你的二元操作符放在开头。然后用乘法替换星号，加一个斜杠，对你矩阵的每一行做一个 unwords，现在这把它变回了一个字符串形式的有效 BQN 表达式。然后直接调用系统 BQN 函数，这实际上是一个评估。总之，所以我确实看了这个，我在脑子里解决了它。我实际上并没有解决它。
put that in a matrix. And it has to be strings at that point because you've got your operation. Do a one rotate on that, or do a transpose, then a one rotate that gets your binary operations at the beginning. And then replace the a a asterisk with a multiplication, add a slash, do an unwords on each row of your matrix now that turns it back into a valid BQN expression in the form of a string. And then just call the system BQN function, which is effectively an evaluate. And anyway, so I did look at this and I solved it in my head. I didn't actually solve it.
但我当时很好奇，没有好奇到真的去写出 B 部分的解决方案，它是否像 A 部分一样好解决？所以我做了和你刚才概述的一样的事情，只是在 Python 中。一次旋转，转置，然后我取头部和尾部。所以旋转一次后，头部是操作符，尾部是归约列表。然后我只是使用操作符字符串在两个函数（加法和乘法）的数组中查找。然后你在 Python 中有类似 eval 的函数吗？不，不，因为，抱歉，这是一个映射查找。这是一个字典，对吧？
But then I was very curious, not curious enough to actually write the solution to what is part B and is it as nice to solve as part A? So I did the same as you just outlined, except in Python. The one rotate, the transpose, and then I take the head and the tail. So after the one rotate, the head is the operator and the tail is the reduction list. And then I just use the operator string to look up into a array of two functions plus and multiply. And then do you have like an eval function in Python or? No, no, because, sorry, it's a map lookup. It's a dictionary, right?
所以星号是函数，operator.mul。是的。对吧？加法是 operator。然后你只是使用该操作在整个列表中进行归约。使用类似 functools reduce 的东西？是的。然后只是把每个字符串变成一个整数？
So star is the function, operator.comole. Yeah. Right? And plus is operator. And then you just reduce using that operation across the list. Using like the funk tools reduce? Yes. And then just turning like each string into an int?
每个字符串。是的，每个字符串已经是一个整数了。是的，抱歉。不，我映射，我映射整数到字符串，跨越列表，跨越列表的尾部。主要的区别是，我正在评估一个……你正在评估一个字符串。你正在对整数进行归约。是的，是的。
Each string. Yeah, each string's already an int. Yeah, sorry. No, I map, I map in to cross the string, across the list, across the tail of the list. The major difference is that I'm evaluating a... You're evaluating a string. You're doing a reduction on the integers. Yeah, yeah.
不过真的很不错。仍然有 90% 是一样的。是的，没错。那么 B 部分是什么？所以我实际上不知道，这对我来说是一个惊喜，因为我从来没有做过 A 部分，实际上。我只是，就像我说的，在脑子里解决了它。对。好吧，现在你可以在五分钟内写出 A 部分的代码了。
Very nice, though. Still, like, 90% the same. Yeah, exactly. And then what was part B? So I don't actually, this is a surprise for me, because I never did part A, actually. I just, like I said, solved it in my head. Right. Well, now you can code up part A in, you know, five minutes.
B 部分就像 A 部分，但转置更棘手，因为事实证明，不仅是，所以 A 部分中的矩阵本身被转置了，在 B 部分中，我不认为我能准确地解释这一点，但数字在列内必须按列读取，而不是按行读取，如果你愿意的话。所以，如果你有一个三个三位数数字的和。
part B is like part A but more tricky transposing because it turns out that not only are the so the matrix itself in part A was transposed in part B the I don't think I'm going to be able to explain this exactly but the numbers are within the column have to be read column-wise instead of row-wise if you're like so so you've got if you've got a sum of like three-three-digit numbers.
那么它们不是那些三位数的数字，而是按列排列的三位数数字。对。所以，我的意思是，在示例的第一列中，数字是 1-2-3，第一行是 123，第二行是 45，第三行是 6。所以如果你转置它，数字现在将是 356，24，和 1，
Then instead of being those three-digit numbers, they are the column-wise three-digit numbers. Right. So, I mean, in the first column of the example, the numbers are 1-2-3, 123 on the first line, 45 on the second line, and 6 on the third line. So if you transpose that, the numbers are now going to be 356, 24, and 1,
类似那样？是的。是的。如果，你保证你有连续的片段吗？或者有，是否可能有一个三位数后面跟着一个一位数，后面跟着一个三位数。它们的长度可以改变，是的。你必须考虑，你必须在某个时候把它们作为列读入，
something like that? Yes. Yeah. What if, are you guaranteed that you have contiguous stretches? Or are there, is there potentially like a three-digit number followed by a one digit number, followed by a three digit number. They can change in their length, yes. You have to take account of, you have to sort of read them in at some point as columns,
因为每一列数字都由一列空格分隔。但在列内，数字可以是左对齐或右对齐的。它们可以是三位数、两位数、一位数，诸如此类。如果你中间有一个间隙，你知道，两位数，那些只是被压缩了吗？所以基本上，如果你在给定的列中，不，那些保持为单独的数字。并且数字必须保持在它在列中的正确对齐方式。对。为了将每个数字视为转置数字中正确的位值。
because each column of numbers is delimited by a column of spaces. But within a column, the numbers can be either left justified or right justified. They can be three digit, two digits, one digit, that sort of thing. If you have a gap in between, you know, two digits, do those just get compacted So basically, so if you have in a given column, no, those stay as separate numbers. And the number has to stay in its right, in its correct justification in the column. Right. In order to treat each digit as its correct place value in the transposed numbers.
所以这周围有一点小把戏。嗯，我的意思是，这让它变得棘手多了。因为如果你只是分割。是的，这就是棘手的部分。你不能只是分割它们并将所有空格折叠成一个空格。是的。如果你做你的 Haskell words，你知道，把它们放在一列里，然后重新构建数字。你知道，那实际上并不太棘手。但如果你需要保持对齐方式与空格所在的位置相对应，那现在你需要像拿刀一样把你的数字切出来并保持它们那样。这远没有那么简单。但尽管如此，还是很有趣。你是怎么做那一个的？和第一个非常相似，只是输入处理略有不同。让我们看看。
So there's a little bit of jiggery pokery around that. Well, I mean, that makes it much more tricky. Because if you can just split. Yes, and that's the tricky part. You can't just split them and collapse all the spaces into one space. Yeah. If you do your Haskell words, you know, put them in a column and then kind of reconstruct the numbers. You know, that's actually not too tricky. But if you need to keep the alignments respective of where the spaces are, that is now you need to like take a knife and cut out your numbers and keep them that way. That is much less trivial. But interesting, nonetheless. How did you do that one? Very similarly to the first one, except with the input processing slightly different. Let's see.
我推迟了分割，就像我们刚才说的那样。所以我逐行读取输入。对于第一个星号，我直接在那一点分割行。对于第二个星号，我做了什么？我必须弄清楚，是的，我必须弄清楚空格在哪里对齐。对。嗯，我的意思是，我们，这是给定的吗？因为根据示例，如果我们只看二元运算，看起来下一个二元运算之前的一个是，是那样吗？所以如果你为第二部分转置整个东西，那么你就把空格列变成了空格行。它们更容易检测。这是一个不错的小技巧。这就是我做的。
I postponed the split, like we were just saying. So I read the input line by line. And for the first star, I just go ahead and split the lines at that point. For the second star, what did I do? I had to figure out, yeah, I have to figure out where the spaces line up. Right. Well, I mean, are we, is it given that because by the example, if we just look at the binary operations, it looks like one before the next binary operation is the, is that, is that the case? So if you transpose the whole thing for the second part, then you turn columns of spaces into rows of spaces. And they're much easier to detect. That's a nice little trick. That's what I did.
非常巧妙。所以然后你，然后你，然后你有点自动地。所以取一行空格只是全部关闭，对吧？所以比普通的空格容易得多。所以一旦你转置了，那么你实际上就免费得到了数字块，然后你可以做进一步的转置和任何其他事情。非常整洁。我会说，比第三天更有趣、更好的问题，
Very cute. So then you, then you know, then you sort of automatically. So taking a row of spaces is just all off, right? So much easier than the commoner spaces. So once you've transposed, then you effectively get the blocks of numbers for free, and then you can do your further transposition and whatever it is. Very neat. I will say, a much more fun, nicer problem than day three,
除非如果你在 C++ 中并且你有 max element。在这种情况下，也许第三天更好。我可以发给你我的……我在 Python 中解决了第六天。这就是解决方案。是的，它很不错。我的意思是，为了节省六个字符，我会做 import operator as op。
unless if you're in C++ plus and when you have max element. In that case, maybe day three is nicer. I can send you my... I solve day six in Python. and there's the solution. Yeah, it's pretty nice. I mean, I would have done import operator as op in order to save yourself six characters there.
当然。是的，你可以在第 32 行看到，我检测空格行的地方。我的意思是，那是数组语言归约的完美位置。空格等于非全部。有一个……所以那实际上是我的……我把 chunk 写成了一个生成器。如你所见。
Sure. Yeah, you can see on line 32, where I detect the rows of spaces. I mean, that's a perfect spot for an array language reduction. Space equals not all. Is there a... So that's actually my... I wrote chunk as a generator. As you can see.
所以我正在产生每个块。哦，我明白了，我明白了。所以那个谓词基本上是块结束的时候，也就是……那个谓词在块还在进行时为真。然后一旦那个谓词失败，你就处于一行空格上，是时候开始下一个块了。是的。
So I'm yielding each chunk. Oh, I see, I see. So that predicate is basically when the chunk ends, which is when the... That predicate is true while the chunk is still going. And then as soon as that predicate fails, you're on a row of spaces and it's time to start the next chunk. Yeah.
嗯，也许在这个发布之前，我会写一个 BQN 版本。让大家看看对比。好吧，我们已经过了 30 分钟了。我们知道这会发生。而且我仍然觉得我们可能还有很多东西可以聊。我们得留到下次了。
Well, maybe before this gets released, I'll code up a BQN version. for folks to see the comparison. All right, well, we're 30 minutes past. We knew this was going to happen. And I still feel like we've probably got a ton of stuff that we could have chatted about. We'll have to save it for another time.
是的，我的意思是，节日快乐，不仅是对你，也是对所有听众。同样。在这一点上，实际上，现在，我不知道，也许是新年了，这是这个的第二部分什么的。因为我不会发布两个小时的播客。这会是快乐的。新年快乐。
Yeah, I mean, happy holidays, not just to you, but everybody listening. Likewise. At this point, actually, now, I don't know, maybe it's the new year, and this is part two or something of this. Because I'm not going to drop a two-hour podcast. This will be happy. Happy New Year to.
1 月 15 日什么的。是的，是的，是的。好吧，希望，我不知道我将如何把它切分，但我认为我会在这个周五发布一个小时的剧集，但所以它可能会被切成三部分。我将如何做，我不确定。但是，是的，叙旧很好。是的。
January 15th or whatever it is. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, hopefully, I don't know how I'm going to dice it up, but I think I'll release an hour episode this Friday, but then so it'll probably be cut into three. How I'm going to do that, I'm not exactly sure. But, yeah, it's been good to catch up. Yeah.
你在 26 年有参加会议的计划吗？还是那是以后的决定？这是一个以后的决定。我怀疑我不会去很多地方旅行。哦，对，是的。所以我的计划，我的默认计划可能是现在的 C++ 和 CPCOM。好的。好吧。
Do you have plans in 26 yet to conference attend? Or that's a down-the-road decision? It's a down-the-road decision. I suspect I won't be traveling a whole lot. Oh, right, yes. So my plan, my default plan is probably C++ now and CPCOM. Okay. All right.
好吧，我们将，如果不在会议上，我们至少会在线聊天。是的。希望我们能在某个时候交集。希望如此。一定要查看这些节目说明，无论是在你的播客应用程序中还是在 ADSP thepodcast.com 上，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里。你可以留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢
Well, we will, if not at a conference, we will, at minimum, get the chat online. Yes. Hopefully we will cross paths at some point. Hope so. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can. you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed
祝你有美好的一天。我是反 Brice。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
and have a great day. I am the anti-brice. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
祝您有愉快的一天。我是反布莱斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。